R
TIME, AND THERE ARE A LOT OF BAD
STORIES RIGHT NOW.
TONY IS ONE OF THE LAWYERS
REPRESENTING STUART SCHELLER AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR DEFENDING
THIS MAN AND FOR COMING ON THE
SHOW TONIGHT.
SO HAVE WE MISSTATED ANYTHING?
IS HE IN JAIL RIGHT NOW?
>> HE IS SITTING IN JAIL RIGHT
NOW WITH NO FORMAL CHARGES
AGAINST HIM.
SUPPOSEDLY THERE IS SUPPOSED TO
BE A HEARING ON THURSDAY, BUT HE
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT HE'S
CHARGED WITH.
AND YOU KNOW, OF COURSE HE STILL
REMAINS UNDER THIS ILLEGAL GAG
ORDER.
>> Tucker: SO THIS STORY BROKE
I THINK LAST NIGHT.
IN THAT TIME, HOW MANY MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS HAVE REACHED OUT TO
YOU TO SAY WE WILL NO LONGER
APPROVE A SINGLE PROMOTION IN
THE U.S. MILITARY UNTIL THIS
PRISONER IS FREED?
A LOT?
>> NONE.
NONE.
IF I WILL TELL YOU WHAT'S MORE
INFURIATING IS THAT TODAY WE HAD
TESTIMONY IN THE SENATE WHERE
THEY TRIED TO MAKE THE CASE THAT
THE WITHDRAWAL WAS AN
OPERATIONAL SUCCESS.
IT'S NOT A SUCCESS OF COURSE FOR
THE 13 FAMILIES WHO LOST LOVED
ONES, AND WHEN SOMEBODY TRIED TO
SPEAK OUT AND SAY LOOK, WE COULD
HAVE DONE A LOT BETTER, WE OWED
THESE MARINES AND SAILORS AND
ARMY PERSONNEL BETTER THAN THAT,
THEY NOT ONLY TOLD HIM TO SHUT
UP AND WHEN HE DIDN'T SHUT UP,
THEY PUT HIM IN JAIL.
>> Tucker: HE'S A MARRIED MAN
WITH CHILDREN?
>> HE'S A MARRIED MAN, YES, WITH
CHILDREN.
AND I WOULD SAY HIS SPIRITS ARE
HIGH.
THE SUPPORT -- NOT OF COURSE
CONGRESSIONAL SUPPORT, BUT THE
SUPPORT THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED,
THAT HE HAS RECEIVED, THAT HIS
FAMILY HAS RECEIVED, AS BEEN
OVERWHELMING.
PEOPLE SEE THIS FOR WHAT IT IS,
THEY SEE THIS THE TOP BRASS
TRYING TO SHIRK RESPONSIBILITY
AND WHAT SUMMARY AND COMMAND
SPEAKS UP, THEY ARE SILENCED AND
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THAT.
THIS IS A MAN WHO IS A 17 YEAR
MARINE, A MARINE OFFICER, AN
INFANTRY OFFICER JUST LIKE I
WAS, A GUY WHO IS CONSCIENCE
REQUIRED HIM TO SPEAK OUT AND
THE AMERICAN MILITARY,
SPECIFICALLY THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS, THE ENTITY IS THAT
LOVE SO MUCH, HAS PUT HIM IN
JAIL FOR THAT, AND PEOPLE ARE
JUST COMING TOGETHER ALL OVER
THE UNITED STATES, THE PIPE
HITTER ORGANIZATION --
FOUNDATION HAS ALREADY RAISED
$200,000 FOR HIS DEFENSE.
THIS IS WRONG AND WILL NOT
STAND.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK OF ALL
THOSE MURMURS OF CONGRESS WHO
SERVED SIX MONTHS AND THE JAGGED
COURSE SOMEWHERE AND BRAG ABOUT
MILITARY SERVICE AND HOW THEY
ARE FOR THE TROOPS, AND HERE
EXTRA $24 BILLION, SAYING NOT
ONE WORD ABOUT THIS HONORABLE
MAN WHO IS THE BEST OF AMERICA
ROTTING IN JAIL WITH CRIMINALS
TONIGHT FOR TELLING THE TRUTH.
IT'S BEYOND BELIEVABL